bienvenue c'est julien courbet et vous
regardez le maillon faible
huit candidats ce soir ils ne sont pas
de la même famille il travaille tous
dans la même émission et pourtant ils ne
peuvent pas se blairer
ils vont pourtant devoir jouer en équipe
vous avez ce soit rejoué mesdames et
messieurs pour l'association ela
vous avez intérêt devons dans cette
première manche deux candidats seront
éliminés par les autres car ils auront
été considérés comme les maillons
faibles dans la deuxième manche il y
aura également deux personnes qui seront
éliminés dans la troisième
une seule jusqu'à la finale où il y aura
un face à face tout de suite mesdames et
messieurs l'équipe qui va jouer avec nos
présentations
je suis prothésiste dentaire et ma mère
bonjour je m'appelle enora j'ai trente
trois ans et j'ai arrêté de boire depuis
trois ans bonjour je suis gérard louvin
42 ans est champion du tuy la vue
bonjour je m'appelle isabelle tu t'en et
j'aimerais qu'ils entretiendraient je
veux bien jouer pour une association
bonjour je m'appelle gilles j'ai 49 ans
je chante et je danse comme personne et
tant mieux d'ailleurs
bonjour jean michel paris les philistins
que j'ai a grossi zié j'ai la faiblesse
de croire
bonjour je m'appelle valérie et j'ai
deux passions le babyliss et la
littérature
bonjour je m'appelle cyril j'ai 20 ans
et j'ai deux passions le pakistan le
frisbee il y a
pour chacune des manches 400 euros à
gagner pour y parvenir le moyen le plus
simple est de former une chaîne de huit
bonnes réponses si l'un de vous répond
mal il brille cette chaîne et fait
perdre à toute l'équipe l'argent qu'elle
venait d'accumuler en revanche si vous
dites banques avant qu'une question soit
posée l'argent est sauvé et vous
recommencez une nouvelle chaîne de
questions ces partis mesdames et
messieurs vous ne rêvez pas sur des huit
nous jouons au maillot la première
question une minute elle vaut 50 euro
commencent à prendre la femelle du bang
mais paris n'avait pas encore argent
jean luc ça démarre très mal comment
s'appelle la femelle du poisson chat ta
chatte le poisson chat tu
c'est une mauvaise réponse c'est le
poisson chat tout simplement arrêté d'y
penser ça vous fera du bien avoué n'aura
selon philippe risoli comment sont les
bananas les patates à ce culte non sur
les bananes halles sont pas les fata de
la nacelle sont cuites assez correct
vrai ou faux gérard louvin le 23 avril
2003 correspond aux derniers jours où
gérard depardieu a vu un verre d'eau
vrai ou faux mais la tienne ce
personnage isabelle de la série le miel
et les abeilles a également joué dans le
film coquin le nain l'avait grosse mais
c'était giants coucou c'est avoue gilles
verdez compléter ces paroles de daft
punk around the world et sexy
alors heureusement mélangé au moins
quatre chansons c'était run the world
from the world vrai ou faux c'est
terminé
mais deux personnes alors nous allons
voir je suppose le nombre d'argent vous
avez pu et l'association va être très
content car regarder grâce à vous ils
vont recevoir déjà grâce à cette
première manche en premier lot 2 0
gb je vais demander chacun d'inscrire
sur l'ardoisé qui est en face de vous le
nom de celui que vous souhaitez albert
et c'est bon si vous êtes prêt on y va
retourner les ardeurs genre commençons
par vous jean-luc vous avez décidé
d'éliminer gérard et gilles je trouve
qu'il ralentisse le groupe enora gérard
isabel qui effectivement pour le coup
ralentit vraiment le groupe gérard me
serais bien éliminer mais bon ils
allaient les gilles gilles ça s'est créé
pas comme ça à l'ail et marc km et
d'isabelle pour nous éliminer
jules gérard isabel c'est plus possible
jean michel gérard isabel trop nul août
valérie gérard et jean michel parce que
je savais que j lo ce serait une catin
j'ai un cyril gérard isabel parce que je
pense à l'association
les deux perdants de cette manche qui
vont nous quitter
sur tout d'abord gérard louvin gérard
vous êtes le maillon faible vous pouvez
sortir couvert de honte vous nous
quittez au revoir au revoir c'est trop
bien je suis éliminé dans cette première
manche le deuxième maillon faible de la
partie et isabelle morini voit ce que
vous nous quittez vous reçoit nous
partons donc sur une deuxième manche
maintenant si vous le voulez bien le
sera un petit peu plus courte deux
éliminés à l'issue de cette deuxième
manche toujours une nouvelle fois pour
50 secondes au maillon faible et nous
repartons les deux hommes jean luc
lemoine e vrai ou faux cécile de ménibus
et vierge
faux c'est vrai son signe du zodiaque et
vierge s'est avoué n'aura comment
s'appelait la première et la dernière
émission de nabila halo nabila c'est
correct
à ce jour mon cher gilles combien de
mise en examen de garde à vue et deux
condamnations samy naceri totalise style
à une près d easynet il y en a treize
désolé vrai ou faux jean-michel
l'animateur julien courbet l'arrière
petit fils du peintre gustave courbet
faut comme l'a dit nicolas sarkozy
effectivement valérie conjuguer le verbe
savoir à la première personne de
l'imparfait du subjonctif que de 6
et bien c'est correct et quand s'est
correctement fait c'est encore mieux et
civils que bois
la vache la vache elle boit de l'eau
elle boit de l'eau effectivement vrai ou
faux josé bové porte une moustache
depuis l'âge de 2 ans et demi est un
faux c'est faux c'est correct
c'est que pour la première manche voyons
combien vous avait totalisé dans ce
maillon faible à l'issue de cette
deuxième manche nous avons un total de
100 toros de corrida
il faut donc éliminer maintenant deux
nouveaux deux candidats je demande à
jean luc et nora gilles jean michel
valery cyril de bien vouloir retourner
leur ardoise jean-luc cvo mémoire que
vous écrivez on y va gilles et valérie
pourquoi je ne sais pas gilles et jean
michel parce que je les trouve moches
gilles jean michel et valérie mais
j'aurais dû dire n aura à michel enault
et jean-luc parce que c'est une gare
c'est un [ __ ] coli
si les officiels parce que gilles j'ai
déjà sauvé cyril gilles et jean michel
parce que c'est ce qu aurait fait toute
personne sensée
cette manche il s'agit tout d'abord de
gilles verdez vous nous quittez gilles
vous êtes le meilleur
le deuxième qui va se traîner la honte
dans les couloirs de des huit pour les
deux prochains mois s'appelle
jean-michel vous nous quittez merci
bonsoir
il est grand temps de passer à la
troisième manche elle sera plus courte
encore à vous de faire monter les gains
maintenant quarante secondes et c'est
parti nous jouons au maillon faire jean
luc lemoine
car s'il faut trois minutes pour cuire
un oeuf à la coque combien de temps
faut-il pour en cuir 2 3 minutes
correctes on les cures même temps quelle
émission présente actuellement sophie
favier n'aura elle n'en présente pas
c'est correct quel chanteur s'appelle
rivière de pénis en français bernard ça
correct
vrai ou faux c'est amanda lear qui a
inspiré le personnage de la série magnum
ou faux durant quelques mois les russes
fait-il la révolution d'octobre lors des
banques en octobre
c'est une mauvaise réponse et en
novembre le 6 novembre 1917 avoué n'aura
quel footballeur a déclaré on est des
joueurs qu'on va vite avec le ballon
ribéry correct combien de temps a duré
la guerre de cent ans passant non c'est
non sans un enfant 12 ans 111 ans 111
116 ans
sa violence le regard dont je suis que
l'argent que vous avez totalisé la
banque nous dit qu'il y a maintenant
regarder 350 euros
à l'éliminer cette fois-ci merci de
marque et le nom du maillon faible sur
votre ardoise jean luc lemoine vous avez
fait votre choix
hier valérie j'ai encore réussi à
délimiter au tour précédent je
m'accroche et laura valérie jean luc est
un ami et cyril et mon patron désolé
valérie savait comme aller dire mon nom
donc j'ai préféré jean luc qui a les
mêmes à battre enfin cyril tout se joue
sur vous valérie puisque la guerre de
cent ans n'a guère préféré nous quitter
car vous êtes le maillon faible au
revoir on va voici donc mesdames et
messieurs la dernière manche avant la
finale c'est maintenant que tout se joue
je vous demande de vous concentrer nous
jouons pour la dernière fois avant la
finale au maillon faible
jean-luc
selon l'expression ou ne faut-il pas
pousser mémé dans les orties correct
comment appelle-t-on les habitants de la
ville de puteaux et nora tous fassent un
peu plus tard être les plus tôt n'est
les putéoliens c'est une mauvaise
réponse cyril hanouna au lieu de traiter
les autres de pouffiasses répondent à
cette question compléter ces paroles 6
juin va bien juba mines
c'est une bonne réponse correcte la
maman de toto a trois enfants riri fifi
et toto taux corrects quel est le pays
où la vie ranchère 1
vous n'écoutez aucune de mes questions
ça m'agace avant quel est le pays où ils
vivent au gers et herman et laura très
bien joué sept manches j'espère que vous
vous en souviendrez regardons maintenant
l'eau au total nous en sommes à 500
l'association ela il n'y aura que deux
finalistes bien sûr l'un d'entre vous va
nous quitter et jean luc lemoine qui
avez vous décidé d'éliminer menora enora
parce que de toute façon je ne pourrai
jamais rien faire avec lm l'a dit vous
êtes clairvoyant et moururent cyril
parce qu'il a traité les meufs de plutôt
de pouffiasses ehpad et des modes
c'était pas du tout c'était les
habitants série wenner alors je vais
vous dire enora parce qu'elle n'a pas su
trouver que conforama été pays où la vie
est moins chère et tendre épouse gala
nous a laissés là où je passe toutes mes
vacances donc ça va merci deux voix
contre une
elle nous quitte enora merci de quitter
le plateau vous êtes le maillon faible
en voir
et voici maintenant la vente final ses 1
100 euros pour l'instant la banque de
2,8
vous êtes deux seigneurs maintenant face
à face et le duel des seniors c'est
comme une série de penalty au football
cette question chacun celui qui en
marquent le plus à gagner et nous
démarrons avec vous jean luc lemoine la
finale b more suis moi ce jour du
registre à quelle heure parce que jusqu
à 2h20 du matin se joue il y à 724
question très bien merci
normalement avec deux jours fait la
grille en terre l'année prochaine ce qui
veut dire que vous n'aurez pas travail
jeudi passé par queen est bien là quelle
est la capitale du brésil où se
déroulera la prochaine coupe du monde de
football rio ce n'est pas la capitale
c'est brasilia à zéro donc c'est à vous
monsieur hanouna
quelle femme politique aurait déclaré
j'ai inspiré obama et ses équipes m'ont
copiée
j'aspire hillary clinton 00 ségolène
royal il est impossible de pleurer dans
l'espace c'est vrai vous avez regardé
l'émission d'hanouna un point quand on
souffre de problèmes d'érection
ininterrompue comme jean michel maire
quelle maladie at-on où on allait on est
là on souffre de deux reina avait pas ce
que deux visiblement on ne l'est pas
mais si j'osais chez trotter c'est le
prix abrisme dans les bronzés font du
ski selon son moniteur de ski qu'est ce
qui ne va pas chez jean claude dusse se
sait
ces écarts c est guère planté mais c'est
plus une rente et de bâtons plan b si le
planter deux bateaux ne prend pas la
réponse et 1 mille près combien
d'entrées a fait le film le baltringue à
vincent lagaf
alors il en a fait dix sept mille noms
41 milan johnny at il appelé zidane lors
d'une interview au 20h de tf1
sazy oui c'est une bonne réponse de
poing vrai ou faux le père fouras était
à l'origine de l'un des membres du
groupe zz top faut effectivement de 1,6
je double le deuxième pendant une course
quel est mon classement
le premier nom en deuxième dans quel
département se trouve mon cul je parle
de la ville montcuq paillis ou bâtiment
partout le lot dans le lot c'est cette
question qui va vous départager
qu'est-ce qui est rose qui fait 5 cm
normalement 15 cm déplier qui fait rêver
toutes les filles de 18 ans le permis de
conduire c'est une bonne réponse
attention quel footballeur est surnommé
la pulga la pulga le pousser ccc mais si
c'est une égalité monsieur madame 2003
hubert
combien de temps j'ai 3 3 et 3 fils
comme on l'appelle style monsieur madame
des fonds un fils john oui qui
interprète louis la brocante
victor lanoux j'ai plus de questions les
enfants vrai ou faux napoléon était le
plus grand est il plus gros que nicolas
sarkozy faux c'est vrai attention vous
pouvez gagner c'est maintenant que tout
se joue cyril hanouna
je ne veux pas en faire des tonnes mais
un gros plan va nous montrer cette
émotion qui est palpable sur le plateau
à 10 minutes près nom qui est patrick
boutot patrick boutot abbas sait qui
c'est patrick boutot sarr l'animateur de
télévision cc non c'est bien c'est
patrick sébastien
vous avez entre jeu
c'est que ce soit
sus aux ans
pas trop bouton peu de sommation bonjour
et oui alors
il est pas bien j'en ai eu marre vous
êtes bien dans tout sport a beaucoup
joué
c'était bon cela nous fait donc ça et
sur d8 le maillon faible
alors sachez qu on a 500 euros pour
l'association ela
je vais faire quelque chose que je ne
fais jamais jamais jamais on n'avait
1600 euros de budget donc on va pas
donner 500 euros pour l'association ela
bon va bien donner les 1600 euros pour
lutter contre la leucodystrophie
voilà et merci julien on s'est régalé
lors d'un sommet jeudi